-Here's how this is gonna work
We're gonna come up with
our very own band
right here on the spot.
First, to do that, we need
a band name, all right?
So, on the count of three,
I want us to each say
a completely random word.
-Okay, let me clear my mind,
'cause I don't want to
do anything preplanned.
Just clear my mind.
-But now you're making lik
it is preplanned, and it's not
-No, no. I just --
-I don't want anyone
at home thinking we pl--
-No, we didn't.
-In fact, you didn't even do
a pre-interview.
You're really --
-No, I'm...
-Yeah. You're really --
Like, you've changed.
-Yeah, a lot.
-Yeah.
-A lot.
-[ British accent ] I grew up.
And you haven't.
-I'm a grown-up now.
-I'm a grown-up,
and you're a child.
-You're a kid.
-You're a babe.
You're a grown man wearing
a diaper.
Wearing a nappy,
the way you were born.
-You got blocks to play with
-That you play with.
-Do that.
-Yeah, try that for once.
Try playin' with blocks an
suckin' on a bottle.
-Do that.
See what that looks like.
-Yeah.
-Not a lot of fun, is it?
-Your mommy won't bring yo
another bottle, will she?
Wah-wah, baby crying,
you know, in a crib.
-Do you want candy?
I haven't got it. Sorry.
-[ Normal voice ]
So, here we go.
We got to make up a band name.
[ Laughter ]
All right,
come up with a band name.
Random word
on the count of three. Ready
-One, two, three...
-Lavender.
-Roller coaster.
-Ooh! Lavender Roller Coaster.
-That's not bad.
-That's pretty good.
That sounds like a
what kind of band to you?
-Lavender Roller Coaster.
-Psychedelic music?
-Kind of --
-'70s?
'60s?
-Kind of psychedelic.
-'60s? Late -- Oh, no.
Lavender Roller Coaster.
-How about this?
Let's get specific.
1969.
-Wow! The year of Woodstock.
-Tail end of the '60s,
going into the '70s
a little bit.
-Wow. We're talking about peace.
We're talking about love.
-Yeah.
-We're talking about --
-Yeah, freethinking.
Things are changing fast.
-Hey, that's right, man. Yeah.
-Yeah, things are changing fast.
-And we won't play
that kind of music here.
-No.
-We play our own music.
-This is happening right here.
-Here, right now.
-Things are changing here.
-In here.
We're gonna change
everything with this song.
-Yeah.
-So now we have to
think of the song.
-That's good,
'cause what kind of -- Okay.
-Lavender Roller Coaster
is the name of the band.
The song is --
On the count of three.
Wait, wait. Sorry.
Let me get into the mind space
-Oh, see? See what I was saying?
-I want to clear my mind.
I just want to just --
-Yeah, let just --
-I just want to just relax
-Just...
-All right.
-All right, let me just
relax for a second. Okay.
I just want to just --
-I wonder if they --
-I'm gonna do some
squat thrusts
and then -- All right, so,
Lavender Roller Coaster is
the name of the band.
All right, the name of the
song -- We'll think of -- Ready?
Lavender Roller Coaster. Ready
On the count of three.
One, two, three...
-Grass.
-Daffodil.
Ooh! We went plants.
-We went plants.
We both went plants.
-We went plants. That's okay
-"Grass and Daffodils"?
-"Daffodil Grass."
-"Daffodil Grass." Okay.
♪♪ Daffodil grass ♪♪
-Daf-- Oh, yeah.
Psychedelic kind of?
[ Psychedelic music plays
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Whoa.
-All right.
-Yeah, okay.
-♪♪ Daffodil grass ♪♪
♪♪ Daffodil grass ♪♪
♪♪ Growing around the garden
-♪♪ The daffodil grass ♪♪
♪♪ The daffodil grass ♪♪
♪♪ Growing inside the corner
♪♪ Disappear, disappear,
disappear ♪♪
♪♪ Disappear ♪♪
♪♪ It's appeal, it's appealing
♪♪ It's appeal, it's appea
it's appealing ♪♪
♪♪ And inside ♪♪
♪♪ Inside of your mind ♪♪
-♪♪ Inside your mind ♪♪
♪♪ Inside your mind ♪♪
♪♪ 40 different colors
inside your mind ♪♪
-♪♪ Inside your mind ♪♪
♪♪ Inside your mind ♪♪
♪♪ Inside ♪♪
♪♪ Your mind ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you so much. Amazing.
Fred Armisen, The Roots.
[ Cheers and applause ]